it's really difficult for me because we
have white people in our family well I
remember you telling me never let
anybody know that do you remember that
you said don't you said no no no ride in
it no what I said was cuz I repeat it
what mommy told me was that you have to
learn to get along with white people but
don't ever bring them home Jada
pinkett-smith and her mom Adrian getting
real about race on their Facebook watch
show red tabletalk it takes practice to
have those difficult conversations with
kindness and consideration and it's just
something that we have to continue to
practice because if we don't talk about
it we're not gonna get to the other side
we're just gonna you know things are
just gonna stay in the cracks and fester
so the more that we can bring these
difficult subjects to light and talk
about it the more we can purify these
subjects and bring them into something
new and so that's what's important for
me was that why you had such a problem
when I was dating John absolutely I had
a white boyfriend he was really white I
mean really why I didn't even give
myself an opportunity to like John very
nice guy just like I said you know we
have people in our family you know and
I've given those people a hard time like
Jason married to a white woman and and
she will tell you
we gave her a hard time before we didn't
welcome her with open arms right and she
really had to prove herself yeah you
know and you know I feel do you think
Tiffany's husband my cousin who she has
a white husband do you think Jason had
to do the same thing don't think so and
I see why is because Jason had a little
bit more swag and he acted more black
wow man and that's just real talk the
talk got even more real from there with
Jada opening up about learning to
understand her uncon
Tobias blonde hair on white women just
triggers means because it's no different
then you get robbed by black guy once
and now you sing all black dudes are
thieves and dangerous
the actress then explained how she
struggles with the feminist movement
because she believes it's grounded in
only helping white middle-class women
this runs deeper than we even are
conscious of right because we embrace a
lot of sense to it the group then pulled
in the show's producer Annie and
anti-racism advocate Jane Elliott to
talk through white privilege and the
history of racism I'm not a white woman
I'm a faded black person my people moves
are from the equator and that's the only
reason my skin is lighter that's all any
white person is because we are great hey
there's race there's one race the human
race and right you all came from the
same black women three hundred thousand
five hundred thousand years ago the
human race began with black win
you